(piano music)
- I grew up Mormon.
(speaks foreign language)
I was Mormon most of my life,
up until a few years ago.
- Hi.
- I then left the Mormon Church,
and that is a whole story
that I want to talk about
today with all of you.
My purpose in doing this
is to share my perspective
so that anyone who is in
a situation like I was
a couple of years ago, who
is questioning and wondering
can have another perspective to lean on.
I'm not looking to get into debates
or to talk about the history
or the theology of the church.
I'll do that in future videos.
Today, all I want to do
is tell you the story
of how and why I left the Mormon Church.
23rd of May, 2000, 2009.
What are we even doing out here, man?
I grew up Mormon.
Both my parents were Mormon
or LDS, Latter-day Saints.
I grew up going to Mormon youth camp.
I then eventually served
a two-year mission
in Tijuana, Mexico, where
for two years, I went around
and spoke to people in
Spanish about the church
and learned a lot, learned
to speak Spanish fluently.
(man speaks foreign language)
- [Man] How you feel?
(speaks foreign language)
(man laughs)
(speaks Spanish)
I then went to the Mormon university
called Brigham Young
University in Provo, Utah,
where I graduated.
I went through all Mormon
rituals in the church and temple.
I worked in the temple as
a volunteer for a time.
I was very, very Mormon,
and I believed it.
I believed deeply in the unique doctrine
of the church of Jesus
Christ of Latter-day Saints,
which is a Christian organization
unlike any other Christian
organization in its doctrine.
(heartfelt music)
The story of how I decided to leave this
really begins with the birth of my son.
Isabelle, who also grew up Mormon,
and I got married in the temple,
which is a huge Mormon ritual.
It's a huge part of being in the church.
We got married in the temple.
We went back to BYU together,
and a few weeks before
we graduated from BYU,
we had a baby, or Ize had a baby.
I didn't have a baby.
She had a baby.
Then we took finals and graduated, like,
literally two weeks later.
Here we are literally in our cap and gown
with Henry, who is, like, two weeks old.
After we graduated, we
moved out to Washington, DC,
and that's when my wheels
really started to turn.
I started to think, you
know, I have a child now.
I have to decide how I raise this child
and what I teach him about the world.
(rolls tongue)
Da, da, da, da, da.
I think having Henry really made me wonder
and think about how I should
teach him about the world.
I'd grown up with this firm
conviction of the LDS doctrine
and its beliefs about the world,
which are very specific and very peculiar.
And I really started to question,
is this what I want to teach my son?
And the answer initially was yes.
I want to teach him everything
that I know about this faith
because I really believed it.
So, we're moving out to Washington, DC,
and I realized that if I'm
gonna teach this to my son,
I need to double down on my faith.
I need to go deeper than I ever have
and really, really establish
a strong foundation
and conviction around this doctrine.
I had one, but I knew
it needed to be stronger
if I was gonna teach my son this.
One of the things I loved about
Mormon doctrine at the time
was that there was always a
push to ask God if it was true.
Not to trust any people
or any organization,
but to, like, get on your knees
and say, God, is this true?
Is this church actually real?
Is all of the things that they
say actually the real deal?
I had kind of taken advantage
of that promise before,
but never really.
I'd always been in a setting of pressure,
whether it was my home as
a kid or my mission or BYU.
In other words, there was
always an incentive to believe.
So I'd never really been in a situation
where I could truly ask this question
and not feel like there
was some price to pay
if I decided I didn't believe.
Being in Washington DC
with my child out on my own
in the workforce was my opportunity,
so I spent an entire year
reading the "Book of
Mormon", going to church.
I had a responsibility at church
that I was putting a lot of work into,
and praying every morning and every night
for some sort of conviction.
I said, I am more earnest and sincere
than I've ever been about this.
I'm willing to listen to any answer.
I just need an answer.
I spent a year doing this.
A year.
That's a long time.
And then I remember this day,
I was biking into Washington, DC,
on a sunny, like, spring day,
and it just hit me in
some really strong way
that no, this isn't working.
I've put in the years of asking
and the effort towards
(sighs) making this work,
and it wasn't working.
This isn't true for me.
And like a switch, it just
so much came out of me,
and I quickly decided that I was done.
I don't think it was all at once.
I think I had been slowly
moving in this direction
for a long time, but
in a moment of clarity,
it clicked for me in a
very satisfying and, like,
very true way.
So Iz, who, Ize, Isabelle,
whatever you want to call her, my wife,
it didn't click for her.
She was not on this journey that I was on.
And I came back and I told her.
I said, I think I am done being Mormon.
And I had always been the sort
of more devout, convicted Mormon.
And she was just like, "What?
"Like, you just, like, have decided
"to be out of this church?"
And she full on said, like,
"This is gonna end our marriage.
"Like, you can't just leave the church."
And I just told her.
I said, "This is where I stand
and this is what I feel,"
and I felt very strongly about it.
Luckily, soon enough,
Ize was on her own path
of reconciling her
thoughts about the church,
her qualms with the church,
and soon she would join me in this path
towards leaving the church.
Now, I call it a path because
that's exactly what it is.
Leaving any Orthodox religion is not easy.
There are layers and
layers of psychological
and cultural conditioning
that you don't even realize
is there until you start to peel it back.
So, even though we started
to leave the church,
we were still going to
church every Sunday,
which I don't really
understand in retrospect.
All I can say is that, like, we were just,
that's what we did every Sunday.
We went to church,
and there was some guilt
if we didn't go to church,
and so we went to church.
But we slowly started to
feel an emptiness towards it,
and over the course of six months,
we finally decided to
stop going to church.
My behavior didn't change all of a sudden.
Like, I didn't leave the church
so I could start drinking
alcohol or coffee or smoking.
Like, that was not a part
of the agenda for me.
I kind of just carried on
exactly how I'd always been,
except for now I looked
around in the world
and I didn't have a doctrinal
theological framework
to understand it, which
was at once exhilarating
and horrifying at the same time.
My existential view had
been so neatly packaged
by the plan of salvation,
which is at the key doctrinal framework
within the Mormon Church,
and that was now gone.
I had no plan.
I had no framework to
make sense of the world.
Exhilarating, but horrifying.
There was also a deep fear
of the cultural and social
repercussions of my decision.
Most of my friends were
still LDS or Mormon,
and, of course, my family was, too.
So was Ize's. And let me just
try to give you a perspective
on why this is such a big deal.
A quick primmer on Mormon theology
is that our whole purpose in life
is to come down here to
Earth to learn and to grow
and to progress and to attain knowledge,
and to fulfill certain we call
them covenants or rituals.
There are four of them
that are really important
to do while you're on Earth,
baptism, confirmation,
this hour-long ritual inside the temple,
and then, called the endowment,
and then the ceiling or marriage.
If you can do those four things,
then you're in really good shape.
You have the knowledge necessary
to go back and live in
the top tier of heaven.
And yes, in Mormon theology,
there are multiple tiers of heaven.
If you're not able to
get these rituals done
while you're on Earth, no worries.
When you're in the next
life, people on Earth
can do all of the rituals
for you when you're dead,
and then you can have those,
the chance to accept those
rituals or those covenants
when you're on the other side.
It's a huge deal.
I had gone through all of the rituals.
I had accepted all of those covenants,
which are very serious covenants.
You wear undergarments that are symbolic
of those covenants that you've made.
People call them, like,
secret underwear or whatever,
but it was just religious clothing
that symbolizes your
commitment to these doctrines.
And the beauty of all of
this within Mormon doctrine
is if you do this and everyone
in your family does this,
then all of you are sealed together
in this never ending
chain of eternal family
that is at the epicenter
of Mormon doctrine.
If you know Mormons
and you know that they
are family-centered,
it's because of this.
The whole doctrine is based
on creating family units
that are all tied into this covenant,
these promises that bind
you, that seal you together
for time and all eternity.
If you've accepted those
covenants, and then you leave,
you break away, you
reject those covenants,
you take off your garments,
you say I'm done with this,
that's a pretty big deal
within the LDS framework.
You are no longer able
to be with your family
in the celestial glory of
the top tier of heaven.
So if you believe that,
and you're a parent,
and you see your child
rejecting those covenants,
rejecting that eternal
ceiling to the family,
you're basically seeing
your child go away,
and you feel like you're losing them.
So unsurprisingly, people
leaving the Mormon Church
creates huge upset within families,
like many other religions.
It's not just an insular
cultural experience.
It is a deeply held
doctrinal theological belief
that if you leave the church,
there are major consequences.
Luckily, I had parents who,
by the time I told them
that I was leaving the church,
were very open and loving
and accepting of my decision.
Certainly, it was hurtful for them,
but they did not project that onto me
in any way that made me feel ostracized.
Unfortunately, that is not the
case for a lot of my friends
and a lot of other people
who have left the church.
But even still, with
parents who were accepting
and loving despite my decision,
I still had years of purging
and processing to do,
something that continues
to this day now four or five years later.
What I didn't realize is
that I had internalized
a lot of assumptions of shame and guilt
and fear and judgment that
I didn't even realize I had.
And for the years following
leaving the church,
it was a process of slowly purging
and peeling back and
processing those things.
I went through the Mister Nice Guy phase,
which is a very common thing for people
who leave the LDS church, which is like,
I'm just leaving the
church nice and peaceful.
I'm gonna not be mean.
I'm not gonna be spiteful
towards the church
because in the church, when you're in it,
there's sort of this, like, archetype
of the spiteful, angry
anti-Mormon who goes out
and spreads lies about the church,
and they're just offended and angry.
And I didn't want to be that person.
I don't want to be that archetype.
And so I tried to maintain
very cordial relationships with everybody.
I tried to be super nice.
Like, you know, the church
was really great for me
and yet I just, you
know, disagreed with it,
so I walked away.
I went through that phase
for a couple of years.
But through therapy
and through a lot of thinking about this,
I came to understand that I actually had
some deep problems and
anger towards the church
and what it instilled in me.
I had anger and resentment
towards a lot of the authority structures
that made me feel unclean or dirty.
I had anger towards the
systems that made me feel
like obedience was the
most important thing,
that submission to a law from
God was much more important
than self-expression
and self-actualization.
I developed a resentment
towards the church structure
that has very homophobic
and heteronormative
and misogynistic structures
that taught me to think in those terms.
A church that purports to love everybody,
but deeply condemns certain
people because of who they love.
I had to rewire so much
of that upon leaving,
and perhaps most frustratingly,
and maybe this is gonna be hard
to communicate the nuance to
to someone who's not LDS,
but I felt deep frustration
at the church's claim
to have a monopoly over
the fullness of truth,
that the few million
members are the only keepers
of the real truth of what
God wants today for us,
and that everyone else has truth, too,
but through prophets and apostles
and modern day revelation,
the Mormons are actually the
ones who have the full picture.
They know what's going on.
I believed that they had the truth
that was going to deliver me and my family
to eternal bliss in celestial glory.
I believed that, and I
modeled my life around it
deep into my adulthood.
And I feel resentment that I did that,
and that the stakes were
so high for leaving,
for expressing myself and
my qualms for this doctrine.
Because after all, if you question it,
you're questioning prophets,
people who are talking to God.
You can't do that.
It all left me very confused
and required a lot of
healing and processing,
and that is still going on.
And let me just be clear about something.
This isn't my millennial brain
trying to reject authority structures
and subvert old institutions
like is happening
in a lot of religious contexts right now.
A lot of people are leaving religion.
I wasn't trying to get away
from some disciplined structure.
My life is still a disciplined structure.
I still have a lot of the artifacts
from my Mormon upbringing.
What I was fleeing when
I left the Mormon Church
was a structure that I feel
like put down who I really was,
made me cover it up in the
name of a broader vision
of what righteousness is and
what Jesus wants me to do.
It wasn't me.
It was harmful towards me,
and it was harmful towards others.
And the consequences were
severe if you spoke up
and you challenged the status quo.
The culture is not one
of discourse and debate.
It's one of obedience,
obedience, obedience, obedience.
Obedience is a hallmark belief
and tenet of the LDS experience,
and as a member, you feel it.
Leaving the church is
painful socially, mentally.
You experience a cost for doing so.
And if you're in that situation now,
which I know some of those watching are,
where you know that your
family and your peers
will think differently of
you if you decide to leave,
just know that it's a lot
better on the other side,
if you choose yourself
and you choose your personal experience
and your personal expression,
and you honor that,
as opposed to honoring
the fear of obedience.
There's some years of pain and adjustment,
but there is a sense of
freedom on the other side.
This is uncomfortable for me to say.
Even right now, I'm imagining
whether it's family or friends
who are still active believers
in the church watching this.
I can feel that discomfort,
even now, years later,
of what are they thinking
of me making this video
and effectively talking to
others who might be in the church
and telling them to leave.
That old archetype of the bitter ex-Mormon
who's polarizing and extremist
is ringing in my ears.
And yet, day by day, those
voices and those old models,
they dissolve more and more,
and they become less loud
and they become less part of my identity.
I, for many years, did identify as someone
who used to be Mormon and now I'm not,
but yet, with time I'm slowly developing
my own new identity that isn't pinned
to my reactionary
experience with the church,
but is just pinned to
who I am, what I love.
I'm a father who loves my children.
I love to learn about the world
and explore and explain things.
I love film, I love animation.
I love moss, I love cooking.
I love reading stories to my boys
and teaching them about the world.
I love traveling.
I love trains.
I love science.
I love the beauty of our world
and the mystery that it is
and the mystery of life and cultures.
That appreciation is enough for me.
I don't have a spiritual
framework to fill the vacuum.
I haven't joined some religion.
Maybe someday I will.
Maybe I will develop that, but for now,
the wonder of the world,
outside of the plan of salvation
and God looking out over his children
for this big plan of obedience,
outside of that, I feel
like there is plenty
to stand in awe of and love
without a God and a savior
to create meaning for me.
And yet, there's a strange
paradox within all of this
that I have to talk about,
which is the Mormon experience
also gave me so much.
My mission, while I feel
conflicted about what I was doing
and how I was doing it,
I learned to work hard.
I learned to speak Spanish.
I learned to navigate
in cultural experiences
outside of my own.
I was in Tijuana for two years
next to a giant international border,
one of the most violent and
intense borders on Earth,
and that instilled a love for the stories
of people who live near borders,
which helped create my career.
My parents raising me in that environment
gave me beautiful
experiences and community,
taught me how to be industrious
and hardworking and disciplined.
It taught me how to care
and love and serve others.
Those are all good things.
So how do I reconcile the pain
and the psychological confusion
that this organization brought to my life,
packaged tightly with the reality
of all of the beautiful things
that it brought to my life?
The good, the community, the memories,
the values of honesty
and service and love?
That's a paradox that will
probably be with me forever.
It's impossible to summarize
this experience as one thing.
good or bad, and that's okay.
That dissonance is okay.
So, that's a little bit of
my story and my thoughts
around why I left the Mormon Church.
I wanna hear from you,
especially those who
have experience with this
and can speak about the complexities.
I also wanna hear from
those who have questions
and are worried or scared.
This isn't an easy decision.
I also want to hear from those
who have experience with this,
whether it's from the Mormon Church
or any other Orthodox
insular religion or culture.
Breaking out of those systems is hard
and sometimes not worth
it, but sometimes it is.
Sometimes it's worth it.
And sometimes on the other
side of that hard journey,
there is a much brighter future.
Hey, thanks for listening, everybody.
Before you go, I want to thank
today's sponsor, Audible,
which is something I've
been using for it feels
like eight years of my life.
Audible is a giant repository
of amazing audiobooks
and other audio content.
I learn so much on Audible,
and I am really grateful that it exists.
The way it works is you
subscribe as a member.
You get one credit every month,
and you can choose any
audiobook in the entire library.
There are tens of thousands
of titles to choose from.
I listen to Audible books
when I'm researching
a story to make me feel more informed
about the story that I'm working on,
as well as just for fun.
Like, I'm listening to this book right now
called "Project Hail Mary" by Andy Weir.
I's like an accessible sci-fi audiobook,
and it's just so delightful.
And the reader is so
good, the performance,
he does all these accents, and, like,
it's just such a joy to listen to.
And it's not just one audiobook
a month that you can get,
which has been plenty for me,
but now they give you
access to this Plus catalog,
which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audiobooks,
original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and
podcasts that are ad free
and some that are totally
exclusive to Audible,
so you can be going
through the Plus catalog.
All of this is included
with your membership,
and in addition to the credit that you get
to get an audiobook.
For me this has been a no brainer.
For literally almost a
decade I've been a member
because Audible just makes a lot of sense.
It's how I learn about the world.
You can try all of this
for 30 days for free,
without paying any money.
So go to audible.com/johnnyharris
or text johnnyharris to the number 500500
to get in on this giant
repository of audio content.
Thank you, Audible for
sponsoring this video,
and thank you all for watching
this more personal video.
I hope it was helpful to some of you,
and I will see you all in the next video,
which is going to be an
explainer, so buckle up for that.
See ya.